first one Peter Griffin uh I'm going to
start by shoplifting from wetzels
pretzels cuz like what are they going to
do like jump over the counter and kill
me for a pretzel Stewie Griffin starting
today no more diaper no more diaper I'm
going to hold it oh oh so maybe
2025 Brian Griffin I'm going to quit
smoking and start
vaping Quagmire uh I'm going to get
unbanned from Hing all
right Sheamus I want to get into yoga so
I can stretch my
pigs Roger I'm going to join a gym so I
can do something about these man
booms and
finally what is Ted's New Year's
resolution you know I want to travel
more cuz uh I've been meaning to visit
your mother's
bedroom come on now